I'm so excited and so this next lady was
the world's most famous singleton in
2001 when she directed the iconic
Bridget Jones's Diary
she brought her back in 2016 - Bridget
Jones's baby and the three core became
huge huge success it made production
companies working title the first
British film company to take 1 billion
at the UK box office it's yeah and as
Bridget would say herself she's very
good its filmmaker of the year sharon
maguire yeah thank you ollie honestly
anyone would think I wrote that list of
superlatives for you myself and I have
to say when I heard who was giving me
the award I squealed like it is when
Patrick Dempsey when I made Patrick
Dempsey's I bear backed into a swimming
pool for 45 takes I love love love use
and use and one of the best bits of
directing these films is to get to meet
pop stars call me shallow and ask them
to record songs for the film and it's a
bit like being Simon Cowell but without
the spank from the Botox yeah right and
and generally comedies and the people
who are in them and who direct them are
overlooked when it comes to award so I'd
like to thank Glamour magazine for
recognizing comedy movies thank you
making these films is a bit like having
a baby except it's a lot more painful
and there are a lot more men involved in
the process I have to admit this one
slipped out much easier than the first
one where delivery resulted in a great
deal more anal tearing
I did wonder whether anal tearing was
too far to go to mind it's the sort of
detail the men involved in the film
wanted me to avoid stick fingers and
ears not listening not listening tonight
I feel in this room of theater and
hairspray I feel I can give full vents
with all anal tearing and gorged breath
perineal massage a vaginal prolapse I
[Applause]
could never thank all the individuals
involved but obviously there's a whole
posse of [ __ ] who are crucial to the
process Renee Zellweger is pretty
important I can't think of anyone I'd
rather be down in the comedy trenches
with than her except of course Colin
Firth who won't mind me naming him as an
honorary [ __ ] and neither will Richard
Curtis thought Hugh Grant and of course
the amazing Helen Fielding who started
all this back in the 90s when we were
all gaily covering up our fear and
loneliness with comedy drugs and alcohol
along with my friend Tracey McLeod who's
been part of the real Bridget Jones crew
here tonight and she's the Edina to my
Patsy I can't just say I'm so excited to
be on the stage with you comedy idol I'm
with Dawn French I mean that this is
such a night for me and finally thanks
to my partner Anand and oh sorry I don't
have to I have to say thanks to the
amazing Helen Fielding who started all
this I've said all that blah blah blah
blah thanks thank you still like partner
Anand who tortured me as an on/off
mainly off boyfriends during the first
Bridget Jones and is now happily chained
as my husband for this particular
Bridget outing and of course thanks also
to the gorgeous fruit of my loins the
two little boys really responsible for
the anal tearing all the internals
it's alright they know about the tearing
I talk about it all the time
finally finally thank you to all my
fantastic new friends at Glamour
magazine for making me feel very special
and for this lovely lovely gift I'm
thrilled thank you
[Applause]